so if baron zemo had to get a kidney
transplant
you would want him to change his name to
has to go to the bathroom more often
no superpowers are weird
let's talk to tom menina to answer this
question what are the most useless
superpowers
in the mcu nina what are the most
useless powers in the mcu
so when you asked me to think about this
question i
knew my answer immediately because i
remember when i saw guardians of the
galaxy
two in theaters i took one look at
mantis and was like
why and uh her superpower being like
just a general vibe check does not seem
super useful to me
um i don't i don't know enough about
kind of her
comics incarnation to know if she has
some other good power
but like i just did a re-watch of uh you
know infinity war and endgame and like
when she's just on thanos's head
camping out up there and is like he's
mad it's like we know
he's mad mantis that's not helpful like
punch him or something
so yeah her like her energy reading
thing
is dumb i don't like it it's not a good
superpower
but a fun character that's my hot take
she's a fun character and i like the
actress it's just like
give her something else to do other than
like be a super psychiatrist or whatever
she's out there doing i don't
i don't see that being useful in any i
haven't seen it be useful yet and i
don't foresee a way in which it will
ever be useful well james gunn is going
to prove you wrong and guardians of the
galaxy
i hope he does again i like the actress
i like the character he
he's got to do something weird and cool
which he's more than capable of doing
have you seen slither
i haven't but i know i probably should
yeah you should
my pick for most useless superpower in
the mcu
is claw okay played by andy circus
in avengers age of ultron
and in black panther so
his deal is that he has a prosthetic arm
that can shoot concussive
pulses and that's
pretty neat i guess his hand
got cut off by ultron
and uh then he got a robot arm and it
shoots
sound you know what might have been more
useful
i don't know like a gun like just a gun
like just carry a gun
right you're on like your arms to use
with your other arm
even right you know it's it's like it
turns it like it shoots
sound waves which i guess it's like so
it's cool to
talk about but at the end of the day
like
what about like i don't know a ballistic
missile or
you know guns a while ago yeah
they're pretty effective and let's also
talk about this i've known about this
character for many many years
it doesn't make sense that his name is
claw does not have a hand
but it is not a claw
his name is claw he should have
at least somebody has a defining feature
about them they should have to like
change their name
i'm saying that if you are going to go
out of your if you're going to name him
claw he should have a claw
he should have a claw or at least be
claw-like in some way like dr claw from
inspector gadget
that's exactly what that is yeah but
that's okay it's like
he's he's evil-ish he's like this is a
problematic world view that you've got
right here brian
he sucks kloss sucks he shows up in one
movie
he's evil he gets his arm cut off he
shows up in the next movie he gets
killed like a chump
claw he sucks and his power sucks use a
gun
so if baron zemo had to get a kidney
transplant
you would want him to change his name to
has to go to the bathroom more often
no i'm just saying
that a claw is a fairly menacing
sounding name
a claw is a weapon what does he fight
with
he fights with his claws not a claw yeah
wolverine
fights with claws claws are a thing
you know any and he has nothing to do
with wolverines
nothing to do with nothing to do
like naming yourself after the thing
that's on your body so your pro
claw is what you're saying you like
ulysses claw
oh i'm sorry man can we go back can you
reintroduce me instead of
you know calling me tom could you just
call me skin tag he's trying to hide on
camera right now
oh my god you need to pull your life
together you need to change your
worldview
okay so skin tag you're trying to hide
on camera please
tell us what are the most useless
superpowers in the mcu
i'm canceling you first of all nina i
hate to disagree with you
but mantis is equal you can talk to and
i'm on board with that
that's basically all i've been looking
for my entire adult life
with little ping pong balls on her head
well now that you put it that way you
know maybe you've awakened something
but i'd rather shift poppy yeah that's
fine
i don't think that mathis is useless who
i do think is useless
is everybody else in the mcu
roast battle nobody's safe ready
starting out with captain america you
took human growth hormones from germany
and you threw a garbage can look at some
people
uh are you trying to be a superhero or
my step-dad chet
boom
iron man i just re-watched your first
couple of movies
uh your power is that you pulled apart
some electronics to make a bulletproof
suit that you wouldn't let the
government take away from you
got bad news for you man you're not
original i live above a methadone clinic
you're a dime a dozen
boom uh the incredible hulk you got
exposed to something that makes you get
angry and weirdly muscular
it's not gamma radiation it's called the
joe rogan experience
[Laughter]
uh black widow you look like scarlett
johansson i've had a crush on you since
i went to see
lost in translation with my step-dad
[ __ ]
what are you my step-back chip
and finally hawkeye hawkeye i
appreciate that you found something that
was important to you and you learned how
to excel at it
i think that's really important not to
mention the fact that you did it while
supporting a family
of three children and a lovely wife too
for you man
to each other you remind me of my
stepdad chip what
another kid on the way there was the
third kid on the way and i think that
they had the name
after uh after aaron taylor johnson
because they felt bad
oh okay okay well
sorry sorry i screwed up
so let me tell you briefly about
porcupine
future telling lady wait is this a real
thing
yes this is a real thing
this is from agents of shield oh again
portuguese
in agents of shield there's this great
character played by ruth nega
and she's great oh i love her her name
is rayna
and she is i believe she's known as like
the woman in the the
flower dress or something like that and
she's very manipulative and creepy and
she's after right she's doing bad guy
things and the whole thing and that sets
up the inhumans
arc where they're going to go through
pterogenesis and she wants to go through
terror genesis so she can get her
inhuman powers
and be super powerful and be super bad
and so she does
and she gets porcupine quills all over
her
and uh she's really upset about it as
happens yeah yeah
she's not into it at all
that's she's like also fair this stinks
that's what she says direct quote this
sticks
but eventually she learns she can also
tell the future
so that happens in humans
but there's no there's no porcupine bite
involved in this
no it's purely it's pterogenesis so
she's wasting
pterogenesis mists uh
and she comes out looking like a uh like
a porcupine
yeah how do you feel about the inhumans
like as a
as a basis for somebody getting
superpower i i i recognize that like on
paper there's nothing that makes it
more or less ridiculous than being a
mutant but for some reason i just never
got on board with it
yeah i don't know i think the inhumans
have potential i think that there's fun
to be had in the inhumans
um but at the end of the day i've
it's i've been kind of hot and cold with
them i think that there's a lot of
interesting things that you could do
with the inhumans but
it's not not my
jam as it were well i mean to
bring it back to what you said at the
beginning or um
actually in a different episode because
time is a flat circle like you know i'm
sure nobody thought guardians of the
galaxy would ever
be popular because it's a really weird
so i think with the right director and
the right cast
almost anything in marvel with some
exceptions could
be could work on screen um but you just
like you need the
the next kind of james gunn type to
really like make it into something good
so i think the inhumans just needs like
a really crack director and cast
if it's can we talk can we talk a bit
about the inhumans and
some of their useless powers could we
black tom do you have feelings how do
you feel
how do i feel about about black people
yeah well in general
man i i gotta say i don't know it's it's
it's just it's one of those subjective
things where uh
it's the same thing with magic in comics
like i i have the same problem with
magic
like doctor strange i could never get
into dr strange because the fact that he
used magic always felt like a cheat code
it was always like well he can just you
know magic harder and then he'll get out
of the situation that he's in
but at the same time everybody in marvel
everybody in comic books they're all
magic
it's just different they just put
different labels on iron man is
technology magic
and spider-man is sticky people magic
and everybody everybody's a different
kind of magic
uh but for some reason it just doesn't
click with me and that's that's the
thing with inhumans i mean
if there had been i don't i don't know
maybe it's just like i never got
into them when i was a kid but like
black bolt
not any different than like an x-man
like there could be an x-man who can't
talk or he'll explode a thing
i like black bolt i like looking at him
right i think he's got a cool character
design but black bolt's power is that
every sound he makes is like super duper
strong
super duper so loud that it will
disintegrate matter in front of him
and so he doesn't talk
as a character it's kind of hard to
connect
when not only can they not say anything
they can't really even
do anything right so he just kind of
stands around a lot and like
gestures of people vaguely in the comics
see i don't know i feel like that could
be like cinematically that could be
really fascinating
it could be interesting if done like
doug jones made that movie
really any time if you just if you get a
good actor behind it then it kind of
rocks
somebody who can't talk and like it
forces the the audience to treat that
character as a mirror i think that could
be
fantastic 100 what they did was they had
like a cranky guy in the uh when they
made the uh
the the inhumans show imax abc
yeah at the tv show okay it was just a
guy who looked kind of
vaguely prepared to have to be doing the
show most of the time but
that doesn't do anything i agree with
everything you're saying but the
his very power is so powerful that he
can't even use it
that's the thing i think that kind of
rocks man i think that that's cool i
think it's uh
it's the same thing that makes it
interesting when superman like holds
back
when he's fighting a bad guy you know
yeah but he still flies
everybody yeah he does yeah i'm saying
he still flies he still lifts
cars he still will throw a punch he'll
still do
a laser vision or a cold breath black
bolt
just doesn't do anything
i want to like black bolt but it's it's
he's engineered to
not do things that you want to watch a
superhero do which is use their
superpowers
okay let's take this from a different
angle then for the last what 13 years
we've been looking at marvel characters
who all have the exact same traits
namely
they're overconfident and they talk too
much this could be a huge change in tone
for the entire franchise to just have
one character who
shuts the hell up the whole time i don't
i'm not against that
you want a quieter more introspective
approach to this
i think that that could be the most
progressive move that the mcu has ever
made is to introduce a white character
who
does not talk wow that would be
just very different sits on his throne
not talking
just just shut up and yeah
all right thanks for joining us please
hit like and subscribe so you don't miss
a single episode